hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
wahrscheinlich hast du gerade hier diese
Vanillekipferl Cheesecake Backmischung
und ich zeige Dich hier in diesem Video
wie du sie ganz einfach zubereitet außer
dieser Packung benötigst du auch nur
ganz wenige Zutaten nämlich diese hier
Butter
Eigelb Frischkäse
und Schlagsahne die zwei Zutaten stelle
ich noch kurz kalt die brauche ich
nämlich später
dann geht's jetzt direkt los ich zeige
euch mal was hier drin ist wir haben
hier einmal die Backmischung
die Mischung für die Creme und
Puderzucker zum Dekorieren plus ihr habt
hier sogar eine Backform die ihr selbst
zusammenfalten könnt natürlich könnt ihr
aber auch wenn ihr einen Tortenring
besitzt das ganze auch in Tortenring
zubereiten aber hier ist alles enthalten
um die Torte zubereiten
und zwar ganz schnell ganz einfach und
ohne großartiges Werkzeug hier nur den
einen Klebepunkt lösen wird
[Musik]
dann nach innen klappen
und den Boden reinlegen
eine Backform
jetzt mache ich den Teig
jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die Backmischung
Butter und Eigelb und verrührt das Ganze
zu dem Teig
dafür nimmt das Handrührgerät oder ihr
könnt den Teig auch gerne mit den Händen
verkneten denn ich komme jetzt sowieso
die Streusel kurz zu dem glatten Teig
und stelle ihn dann abgedeckt für eine
Stunde in den Kühlschrank
[Musik]
nach einer Stunde könnt ihr den Teig
einmal kurz durchkneten ein Drittel
davon nehme ich jetzt direkt Weg daraus
vor mich nämlich die Kipfer das heißt
einfach eine Rolle mit etwa 1 cm
Durchmesser steht aber auch alles auf
der Verpackung hier Formen und ich mache
jetzt einfach 8 Kipfel schneide ich hier
4 cm Rollen ab und Form sie so klein wie
so kleine Hörnchen
wenn ihr braucht ein bisschen Mehl
benutzen aber eigentlich brauche ich ja
fast
[Musik]
jetzt müsste die nämlich nur noch an den
Enden so ein bisschen spitz zu räumen
und den restlichen Teig gebt ihr jetzt
hier in die Backform gerne ein bisschen
Mehl ihr könntest du mit den Fingern ein
bisschen glatt drücken
in die Form rein
und dann am besten mit einer Gabel
mehrmals einstechen damit er auch schön
am Boden bleibt und dann kommt beides
gleichzeitig auf ein Blech und kurz in
den Backofen den dürft ihr auch gerne
schon vorheizen
[Musik]
10 bis 12 Minuten bis die Spitzen so ein
bisschen braun sind
[Musik]
die sehen super aus dass ich jetzt kurz
beides abkühlen und dann geht's direkt
an die Creme
der Boden und die Kipfer sind jetzt
abgekühlt jetzt könnt ihr eure Sahne
noch dazu nehmen den Frischkäse und noch
die Creme Pulver Verpackung das alles
gibt ihr hier in die Rührschüssel
verrührt kurz bei niedriger Stufe und
dann einfach bei höchster Stufe 1 Minute
lang
[Musik]
so sieht die Creme jetzt aus richtig
schön standfest und die kommt jetzt hier
direkt auf den abgekühlten Boden
und wenn ihr wollt lasst es wellig wenn
ihr wollt streicht das glatt ganz wie
ihr mögt das muss dann auch nur noch für
eine Stunde in den Kühlschrank oder ist
die Torte fast schon fertig
zumindest fertig zum dekorieren
jetzt der Cheesecake gut ausgekühlt
bevor ich ihn jetzt aus der Form
rausnehme habe ich jetzt hier noch die
Vanillekipferl nehme den Puderzucker und
steigt den einmal drüber könnte so aus
der Tüte machen oder auch gerne durch
den sie geben
[Musik]
einfach die Backform lösen
und jetzt noch die Kipferl draufsetzen
schon fertig
[Musik]
und so einfach backt ihr einen
Vanillekipferl Cheesecake mit meiner
Backmischung ich wünsche euch ganz viel
Spaß dabei einen guten Appetit die Torte
ist wirklich richtig lecker und vor
allem das perfekte Mitbringsel zu einem
Adventssonntag oder einfach mal so wenn
ihr Lust auf einen süßen habt
[Musik]